mic we were just talking about who
should be the highest-paid player in the
league if we take away quarterbacks here
who would you put in that position well
if it's a football decision you get a
look at pass rushers I think if you're
talking about what kind of an impact
someone can have on a team from a
marketing standpoint selling tickets etc
then maybe you look at an Odell Beckham
jr. a guy that excites a fanbase a guy
that turns a team into a national brand
like Odell Beckham jr. would do but I
say typically it goes quarterback and
then pass rusher do you think this is
going to be a big deal with Odell
Beckham saying he would like to be
there's nothing wrong the thing I'd like
to be the highest-paid player but when
you demand to be the highest-paid player
then it becomes an issue which I don't
believe he's demanded anything yet but
where are we going with contract talks
with Beckham well here's the challenge
for the dive because they have Odell
Beckham jr. for two more years before he
would be eligible for the franchise bag
I think the closer he gets to the
franchise tag Dan the more likely he has
a Kirk Cousins type of realization that
you know what I can make a lot more
money and I can control my destiny if I
just say I'm not doing a long-term
contract I'll take the franchise tag in
2019
I'll take it in 2020 I'll take it in
2021 I'll keep making more and more
money and eventually you won't be able
to sign me and I'll hit the open market
and I think that the Giants would be
wise to put together a really good offer
get it on the table now when he's only
making 1.8 million this year and you're
going to replace that with a huge payday
do it now before he starts to realize
that he can play this out like Kirk
Cousins did and make a lot more money
that way least valuable position in the
NFL is one other than kicker and hunter
and yeah running back didn't used to be
right well here's what happened
remember what Reggie Bush was the second
overall pick in 2006 and we thought he
was going to be the next Gale Sayers
he goes to New Orleans and they use
three running backs all the time you
know at some point the team's realized
we can take this position where we used
to have a work force who would end up
getting paid a lot of money by the time
we pay him all that money he's not
nearly as good anymore like a Shawn
Alexander who fell apart a year or two
after he got his big contract so we
the position we use multiple players
nobody becomes a superstar and we don't
have to overpay a running back and we
and we can find it it occurred to me
about ten years ago or so dan I used to
go to all the West Virginia football
games and every major college has a guy
that you could put in the NFL if you
block for him if you teach him how to
hold on to the football when he's hit by
a grown man and if you trust him in pass
protection you can have plenty of
running backs who can get it done and I
think the NFL realized these are far
more interchangeable than we previously
believed so we're going to undermine
this position and that's why there's so
many good running backs that are out
there first round of the draft second
round all the way through to undrafted
but then let me look at the Dallas
Cowboys situation with dak Prescott and
Ezekiel Elliott who's more important
who's going to be the guy who gets the
big contract out of those two the
quarterback he's going to play longer
you know with his ego Elliott they may
just chew him up and he may be done in
five or six years now short term I think
it's important to have a zql a because
that Prescott still learning and I think
this is one of the reasons why Jerry
Jones is is very skittish about the idea
of it's the first couple games of the
year if he get suspended
you've got changes on the offensive line
you've got defenses that have had seven
months to figure out how to stop that
Prescott you take away the primary
balance that is going to help that
Prescott you take away as EQ Elliott all
of a sudden it's all on back Prescott
and then you got to worry about church
without EQ Elliott there to you know to
keep the defenses on it before your
phone kind of witch's out on me here
Colin Kapernick the possibility with the
Ravens is what now of latching on 0 oh
it's over because they brought in Olson
a guy nobody ever heard of from a team
nobody ever heard of in a league nobody
ever heard of but if a camp farm I mean
and that's been that'll be the excuse
for the next month we're signing camp
arms and Colin Kaepernick is in a camp
farm and is anybody even offered to make
him a camp arm I don't know I think they
were afraid to offer him that job
because they're afraid he's gonna fail
take it all I thought there was a little
momentum there that maybe with John
Harbaugh
and Jim coached him in San Francisco and
his offensive coordinator is there with
the Ravens that
kind of made of perfect fit for him and
I know the Flacco injury we don't know
the severity of let's say there's a
little bit more to the Flacco injury is
there a little bit more to the
Kaepernick situation then well I think
there should be hey I already think he
should be number two instead of Ryan
Mallett yeah but I look there are
decisions being made at much higher
level than coach or GM when it comes to
Colin Kaepernick at many NFL team and I
think we all know that right thank you
Mike have a great weekend we appreciate
it
all right Dan see buddy that's Mike
Florio Pro Football Talk live is back on
NBC sports radio and NBC Sports Network
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience